[Music]
you look gorgeous as always I've been
seeing you a lot lately your billboards
for the client list around town yes and
I see them and I stare at them as I
Drive by and then crash into pedestrians
we okay but I want to show you they
seems like they changed the billboard
strategy yeah is that fair to say
yes they did okay last year this was the
Billboard and quite quite risque quite
revealing yes and I have a copy and then
that changed to the one this year which
is a little more covered up but covered
with those aren't real people at first
when I saw that that those were real
people and I called 911 Oriya was
invaded yeah yeah hang there all day
yeah and then I noticed they weren't
moving I thought oh they died but um
what was the what was there a philosophy
behind the the change there's a bit of a
scandal with the first billboards
because there was the one that you
showed and then there was another one as
me laying down in a nude sort of bra I
remember that yes I remember yeah and
everybody loved it
watch the show everybody was happy there
was one group of people who apparently
were offended by the Billboard and were
not into it and so next thing we knew
there was this [ __ ] was just a group
of eighteenth-century nuns
we still don't know who it was like it
happened in a magazine but we don't know
who actually did the fixing of the photo
but they didn't ask anybody if they
could do it covered you up and covered
me up and they actually made me like a
cup and a half size smaller and then
covered everything and it was sort of
like unamerican yeah that's we fought
wars over this kind of thing absolutely
no-one can reduce your cup size without
well half the town is going out to make
them bigger so it didn't make any sense
right and then so my billboard is there
right and I'm being made smaller but
right next to it is David Beckham in his
underwear for H&M like couldn't have had
a bigger situation in that billboard and
he is out there like hello and I'm like
hi and it was because I saw his
billboard it actually talked as you
drove off
it's ridiculous all the kid came at me
and traffic and there was no problem
with that but I had to have smaller
boobs it was very strange so then when
they got ready to do the new campaign
they were like well we'll go somewhere
in the middle and try not to offend
people this time so they put tiny men
crawling on me I don't really know yeah
I don't know I don't know what that
solves um I don't either but either was
five let me ask you about this yeah
you're on the cover of shape magazine
look beautiful as you always do in
everything and a gorgeous photographs of
you in here and you're you know you're
wearing a quite you know revealing
outfits and I'm just curious do you get
when you're in that kind of a situation
is that nerve wracking or kind of in a
weird way is it fun I have no idea if I
were to have to appear in a bathing suit
somewhere yeah I just start I just I'd
cry I just cried fine I did a little bit
of crying it was very nerve I first of
all the people shape are amazing and
they're awesome and they make you feel
totally comfortable but you walk in at
like 8 o'clock in the morning and
there's five hundred bathing suits
and fluorescent lighting and you're like
oh my god this is not gonna go well oh
and it's very panicky and then you sort
of tried them on and for living in my
new job I wear lingerie and everything
yes which I feel fine about it never
really gives me any pause or anything
but this was very nerve-wracking but it
turned out well and I was super
flattered and who's now is it is there
someone they are telling you what
bathing suit to where is there a creepy
guy and how do you get that job
it was the guy saying try that one now
turn around I mean who's doing that no
you have to walk out into like a
committee of people in your bathing suit
and be like committee is a committee
small committee and you're like hey
everybody and they're like oh no not
that one and you're like that not me in
this one or not the bathing suit or
would we get self-conscious but they're
great they they do like you'll try them
all you're petting a kid I'm here by the
way everybody else eats lunch around you
while you're in the bathing suit and
you're like really can you not eat your
lunch later I'm in this bathing suit I
can't eat anything I'm sucking on ice
cubes come on it's not how it works I
had no idea I didn't okay it's fun it's
fun and they were great and I was
flattered